hi and welcome to my video series of
mole bio explained in three minutes
where I explain a concept in mall
biology in less than three minutes if
you haven't yet subscribe to my channel
hit that subscribe button today we would
talk about the use of alkaline
phosphatase and poly nucleotide kinase
in molecular biology both alkaline
phosphatase and poly nucleotide kinase
are super useful tools in case of
cloning so if we remember the cloning
workflow some time what happens is while
we digest the vector even though insert
is present and the insert could be
possibly inserted in either vector there
could be all also a possibility of self
ligation so the self ligated plasmid is
a big problem so if you keep the plasmid
for long there could be self ligation of
the plasmid now what happens is when you
cut the restriction cut the plasmid with
restriction enzyme there are ends with
phosphate and hydroxyl but this can rely
get to each other if they are not be
phosphorylated in order to prevent the
realization or self ligation these ends
can be d phosphorylated using the enzyme
alkaline phosphatase as a result at the
end would have only hydroxyl group and
these cannot rely get to each other and
this prevent the probability of
relocation and increase the efficiency
of cloning especially when we are using
PCR products as an insert it is not like
it it is not phosphorylated at the end
in order to phosphorylate that we can
use poly nucleotide kinase to
phosphorylate the ends of the PCR
product there by default for editing the
vector and phosphorylating the insert
increase the efficiency of the cloning
now in labeling kin and in labeling
could be achieved by the usage of
alkaline phosphatase and pnk in
combination so let us look at it let's
say
this is a DNA and we want to label the
end of these DNA so we know the five
prime end there would be phosphate group
so what we can do is first use alkaline
phosphatase to cleave off those five
prime phosphate and add hydroxyl group
into that but now we would reef also
write it with the help of poly
nucleotide kinase
the boy knew chloride kinase could add
phosphate group now in the solution
while using poly nucleotide kinase we
can give P 32 labeled phosphate groups
as a result the end of these DNA
fragments would be labeled as labeled by
radioactive phosphorus now once it is
labeled I mean it can so when we provide
radio labeled nucleotide radula build
ATP poly nucleotide kinase incorporate
the radio level into the phosphate group
and put it in the five prime end and
this strategy could be used in case of
southern blotting and in situ
hybridization etc so how come in
phosphatase and t4 poly nucleotide
kinase both are really important to in
molecular biology I hope you enjoyed
this video if you liked this video give
it a big thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you